but as we started to prepare our show I
realized one dreadful predicament you're
American yes as American as the open
road hot pockets soccer you mean
football yes yes madam our lesson
learned
Channing Tatum there with a slight
British accent and that promo for Magic
Mike live in London now before tonight's
premiere I have my own magical moment
with Channing and the men of Magic Mike
live as they spread holiday cheer all
over London it was really cool but you
know what this city has a special place
and proud papa channing tatum's heart we
got all the guys on here we're gonna run
around your waist and take it away some
stuff this is just a big deal for us I
love London so much my daughter was born
here I love it yeah it's crazy I've been
travelling back like for two days then
going back two days three days and then
going back so I can't travel that much I
stalk your Instagram you know and I saw
y'all make out were you making anyway
what was that concoction slime all the
kids love the slime these days did you
get it off your hands
it took a minute the first batch I made
it the wrong consistency but somehow she
fixed it she's five she fixed it better
than I could
one double-decker bus
chanting in the middle of 13 male
strippers now the cold London rain made
the guys cover up all this goodness but
hey we are not complaining
do you guys have an area of expertise
I'm Ellie breakdance Oh
[Music]
is there a group chant at the beginning
like y'all get what makes y'all fight
the crew surprised fans handing out
tickets to the Magic Mike London show
two tickets to Magic Mike Glenda and
while you may appreciate the men for
these vine moves Channing make this
confession it's not easy to give a lap
dance so thank you it's just not like
you got to enter somebody's space and a
wait you know in a way that isn't
intrusive that isn't like making
somebody kind of go I'm scared now
and we found good guys they got good
mama
relationships or something because love
your mama you can give me a 2-0 like you
know that's a headline Channing Tatum
says it's not easy to give a lap guys
it's not easy listen we're gonna have
much more with Channing and the guys
from Magic Mike to their big premiere
we'll have all of that for you tomorrow
because look we all need a little more
chanting in our lives right Nance ah
certainly not a bad thing easy that's
for sure thank you very much
[Music]